Vsauce!
Kevin here -- with a math crime so sinister
the Michigan Supreme Court stated that no
other game operated more extensively or demoralized
so many people.
City police forces repeatedly shut it down,
and the FBI waged all-out war against it.
And it made criminals out of people like…
a Detroit mom named Miss Fannie.
What they didn’t know is that they were
fighting against a nearly perfect game that
was about way more than just beating the odds.
In Atlanta, it was called “Playing The Bug”
-- in Harlem and elsewhere, it was still called
“Policy” after the original game that
drew numbers from 1 to 78.
But the real name is just “Numbers” -- and
although it was associated with black communities,
everyone played the Numbers.
When Fannie Davis set up her Detroit neighborhood
Numbers game in 1958, there just wasn’t
much economic opportunity for the black community
-- so, she started her own business.
And she funded it after winning big on Numbers
herself.
It worked like this.
You’d place a bet on a 3-digit number from
000 to 999, and that could hit one of two
ways.
You could play it straight, where you hoped
to hit the exact number -- like, 607 -- and
you’d be paid 500 or 600 times your bet.
Or you could bet a number “boxed,” meaning
you’d win if any combination of your numbers
hit.
That’s 3!, so 3 x 2 x 1 = 6 possible combinations
[607, 670, 760, 706, 067, 076], and it would
pay about 80 to 1.
Okay.
So.
How did they choose the winning number?
I’ve got a cage full of balls numbered 1
to 100 -- I’ll give it a crank and then
I’ll draw three.
I’m gonna play: 394.
That’s my lucky number because .394 was
Tony Gwynn’s batting average in 1994 when
he was on pace to hit over .400 for the first
time since Ted Williams hit .406 in 1941,
but a labor strike shortened the baseball
season and RUINED EVERYTHING.
Okay.
Here we go… 32.
I already lost.
Oh well let’s keep going.
Oh.
My cage of balls broke.
I am a fool.
Oh there’s so many on the floor.
Alright let’s finish this off.
Stay closed.
86.
Last number.
91.
The winning number was 261, my number is 394.
Sorry, Tony...
But… this method is silly.
No one would trust a guy pulling balls out
of a cage in his house.
To get the winning number in a more fair manner…
I could do something like… take 3 YouTube
videos, reload them each day on a livestream
and use the ones digit from the view counts
to pick the winning number.
And Fannie’s game worked kinda similar to
that.
She used the “mutuel” from a local racetrack
-- the betting totals for win, place, and
show on a series of horse races.
She’d take the ones digit from the 4th,
5th, and 6th race totals, and there’s your
3 numbers.
It was technically possible to influence those
digits, but incredibly difficult -- and expensive.
Other games used independent numbers like
digits from the published daily balance of
the US Treasury -- things you could open up
a newspaper and see.
Look, here’s the real beauty of Numbers
and why it worked so well for Fannie and her
community: You win just often enough to enjoy
playing, and to validate every possible betting
system.
If you play 6 days a week you’ll probably
win boxed 2 or 3 times a year, and you’ll
hit straight for 500 times your bet every
few years.
Did a number come to you in a dream?
Do you think you have a scientific lottery-beating
system?
They all end up winning.
And yeah, the house edge was steep -- getting
paid 500 to 1 on something you know has a
1 in 1,000 chance of happening means someone’s
making money somewhere.
They’re also taking bets, keeping meticulous
records, collecting money from losses and
distributing money from wins -- all as they’re
calculating their own mathematical risk of
ruin in real-time to make sure they can survive
financially if someone hits big.
But for Fannie’s neighbors, they could see
$1 become $500 overnight.
The FBI saw an opportunity to rip it away
from them and give it to… someone else.
We’ll get to that in a second.
This video is sponsored by Fabulous.
About 80% of New Year's Resolutions fail within
the first 2 months because habit changing
and building are hard.
Fabulous was developed at Duke University’s
Center for Advanced Hindsight and is designed
to help you create long-lasting change in
your daily routine.
Based on behavioral science and decades of
research, it works by breaking down healthy
habits into very small tasks that you can
easily achieve every single day.
So whether your goal is to exercise more,
sleep better, eat healthier or dedicate yourself
to an any% speedrun personal best of Ninja
Gaiden III for the NES, Fabulous offers a
self-guided approach to better habit-forming
-- and if you want a guided approach?
They have that, too.
Use it to start building your ideal daily
routine right now.
The first 100 people who click the link below
will get 25% OFF a Fabulous subscription!
Thanks to Fabulous for supporting Vsauce2.
Okay.
Law enforcement called the Numbers game racketeering,
and in 1970 the FBI led what J Edgar Hoover
called the largest gambling raid in history,
shutting down 58 Numbers operators.
Then governments realized that if the house
always wins, they could just… become the
house.
States made Numbers illegal, did their best
to wipe it out, and then gave themselves a
legal Numbers monopoly.
Wow!
What a neat trick!
Lotteries have actually had a really complex
history in the United States -- from the colonial
period to early statehood, hundreds of lotteries
helped raise money for schools and public
works.
By the 1830’s, lotteries were denounced
by social reformers as morally bankrupt, predatory
games that generated “tainted revenue”
-- and in 1895 lottery games were banned nationwide.
From legal lotteries to policy houses, there
was enough corruption and game-fixing to consider
what was best for the public interest.
Now 44 states have legalized lotteries, and
the Powerball is played in all of them -- to
help raise money for schools and public works.
And we’ve come full circle.
But the reality is to run a game like Numbers,
what you really need is the trust of your
community.
Fannie Davis and other boutique Numbers operators
engaged in a sort of prescient scholarship
decades before neuroscience and psychology
research confirmed what they harnessed intuitively
-- the community element of Numbers was everything.
They seized the power of Dunbar’s Number,
building on the social cohesion in well-connected
neighborhoods so everyone could play a game
together — and that’s completely lost
when 100,000 strangers play a lottery anonymously
at a gas station.
They knew that throwing in just one additional
number meant only hitting straight once every
30 years -- that’s probably once in a lifetime.
And that’s not often enough for most people
to wanna keep playing, even if it increases
the prizes dramatically.
They intuited the communal strength of Rene
Girard’s mimetic desire, and how much people
love playing games together -- and need to.
And they actually knew how to make a small
economy work: Numbers created tens of thousands
of jobs within communities trying to survive
in the face of discrimination, segregation
and rampant racism.
A 1903 Detroit Free Press article said Numbers
was “largely the gambling field of the ignorant,
superstitious, and poor… the main thing
is to have the evil eternally wiped out.”
Lottery ban legislation was a patronizing
attempt to protect communities from themselves.
Now we’ve got Japan’s Takarakuji, South
Korea’s Lotto 6/45, the US Mega Millions
and Russia’s Gosloto -- in addition to US
state games that operate exactly like Numbers
did decades ago.
Pennsylvania even named their 3-digit lottery
“The Daily Number.”
But those games can’t do what people like
Fannie Davis did in Detroit.
There’s no talk at the diner about who won
that week or who hasn’t hit in ages.
There’s no knock on the door to deliver
your lucky payout the day after your numbers
match.
There’s no playing 357 because you live
at 357 Park Drive and everyone knowing when
that number hit – YOU were the winner.
That’s all gone.
There’s enough intrigue about Fannie Davis’s
life and her Numbers game to fill a great
docuseries -- and there were thousands like
her.
Read Bridgett Davis’s book about her mom
-- that’s her story to tell, not mine.
Check out Felicia George’s dissertation
about Numbers in Detroit, or Louise Meriwether’s
novel “Daddy was a Number Runner” -- you’ve
heard a million stories about the good guys
and bad guys during Prohibition.
But Numbers stories like Miss Fannie’s have
been almost entirely ignored.
But they shouldn’t be.
Because alongside the rackets were people
who understood the social fabric of their
communities.
Making your own way in the world and making
everyone else a little bit happier?
That’s not the American Dream, that’s
everyone’s dream.
But the highly-regulated mass-production of
fun strips the complex social function from
a game that’s the perfect blend of math
and people.
It’s reduced to lonely, anonymous gambling.
And when that happens, the only thing left
is just… numbers.
And as always, thanks for watching.